en quoi la pandémie a fait bondir la
faim dans le monde
en fait la pandémie a démontré la
fragilité de nos systèmes alimentaires
mondialisé avec une spécialisation
de sueur principalement quelques grandes
cultures et des échanges commerciaux
très important et une grande partie des
aliments sont transportés d'une partie
de la planète à l'autre et lorsque ces
systèmes de transport sont
mis en difficulté à cause de la pandémie
sacré eu des conséquences très
importantes pour la sécurité alimentaire
la sécurité alimentaire il a aussi
fortement augmenté les prix ce qui a eu
un impact très important sur les gens
les plus pauvres et augmentant de façon
significative la faim dans le monde
et donc on se rend compte que c'est
peut-être pas la quantité de nourriture
qui manque qui aurait assez de
nourriture pour tout le monde le
problème c'est l'accessibilité
absolument il faut savoir tout d'abord
qu'un tiers de l'alimentation
des produits alimentaires qui seront
produits sont gaspillées ou perdus et ne
sont jamais utilisées et puis une grande
partie également est utilisé comme
biocarburant est
également des grandes surfaces sont
utilisés pour des cultures qui ne sont
pas vivrières et donc ils l'accent a été
mis plus sur des cultures d'exportation
plutôt que la de se focaliser sur la
production d'aliments localement et ça
c'est une un des grands problèmes qui a
montré là la fragilité de de notre
système alimentaire actuelle oui
j'aimerais bien monsieur prison vous me
donnez des exemples parce que en effet
il ya des pays qui sont dans des
situations de grande vulnérabilité
parce qu'ils n'ont pas ce qu'on appelle
ce qui est désormais un peu sur toutes
les lèvres ils ont peur la fameuse
souveraineté alimentaire
exactement beaucoup de politiques
nationales
sont une continuation encore des
politiques coloniales et postcoloniales
où
l'accent a été mis sur la production
dans les pays en voie de développement
sur des cultures de rente telles que le
coton ou le cacao le café ou le palmier
à huile et
de ce fait la grande production n'était
pas destiné aux populations locales mais
à l'exportation et donc ces pays là sont
des grands importateurs de nourriture et
lorsqu'ils les marchés internationaux
sont en difficulté et ce sont les
premiers à souffrir et donc ils n'ont
pas cette souveraineté alimentaire et on
voit maintenant que des pays comme la
france
avec la crise du coc vie parle également
de souveraineté alimentaire même au
niveau de la france et donc ça montre
vraiment que les systèmes alimentaires
actuels ont besoin d'être repensé en
profondeur
le rapport de l'onu monsieur frison
n'intègre pas encore l'impact de la
guerre en ukraine parce que c'est très
sain est ce que l'on se dirige vers une
crise selon vous plus grave encore
oui mais il faut pas oublier que ce
n'est pas uniquement la crise du coc
vite qui a mené à l'augmentation de la
faim dans le monde en fait depuis 2015
on voit une augmentation du nombre de
personnes souffrant d'insécurité
alimentaire et donc le coc vide a
évidemment été responsable d'une
augmentation significative et la guerre
en ukraine risque de d'exacerber encore
ce problème mais c'est une indication
que il faut vraiment repenser les
systèmes en profondeur on a déjà connu
trois crise des prix alimentaires en 15
ans tout d'abord en 2007 2008 et puis en
2010 2012 et puis maintenant en 2020
2021 or on n'a pas tiré les leçons des
des crises précédentes et on a continué
sur la même lancée de toujours
centraliser plus et aller vers des
systèmes alimentaires de plus en plus
mondialisé et qui sont très fragiles oui
en même temps certains diraient ces
grands systèmes agroalimentaires
permettent de produire massivement à
moindre coût c'est un argument qui est
souvent avancé qu'est ce que vous
répondez à st
en fait le système que j'appellerais un
système de production industrielle a
montré sa fragilité également et ses
limites on voit que dans les zones de
production les plus intensives que ce
soit aux états unis au japon ou en
france les rendements à l'hectare sont
en train d'être plafonné et même diminue
malgré l'augmentation des intrants qui
sont utilisés parce que le système n'est
pas durable ce sont des systèmes basés
sur des intrants externes de
fertilisants chimiques et de pesticides
qui détruisent la santé des sols et qui
empêche un bon fonctionnement de
l'écosystème et donc il faut repenser en
profondeur et aller vers des systèmes
diversifiée et agro écologique
c'est-à-dire qui
fonctionne comme fonctionne la nature
avec une très grande importance des
micro organismes qui sont dans le sol
mais surtout aussi la diversité des
espèces qui sont cultivées est élevé
parce qu'elle crée des synergies entre
elles pour avoir un système qui est
beaucoup plus résilient notamment
vis-à-vis du climat et des changements
climatiques qui deviennent de plus en
plus problématique aujourd'hui merci
beaucoup monsieur prison ça a été un
plaisir de vous parler on va suivre
évidemment tout ça de près
merci beaucoup c'est un plaisir